bonsoir lucie bonsoir à tous et oui ça y
est c'est le grand jour après six ans de
travaux
après les terribles inondations de juin
2016 ça y est le musée j'ai rodez et
rouvert c'est un événement ici à
montargis les premiers visiteurs sont
arrivés à 17h tout à l'heure pour
découvrir redécouvrir ce lieu
d'exception entièrement rénové ses
oeuvres restaurées et je vous propose
d'écouter leurs premières impressions
tout est fait pour le visiteur pour le
coup d'oeil pour le coût d'ensemble
alors qu'avant c'était un petit peu on
avait un peu le nez contre le mur là
c'est vraiment très agréable
l'endroit est merveilleux et les toiles
sont très très belles fêtes de montargis
non du tout de la région parisienne
donc on est venus pour l'occasion et
c'est vraiment très beau c'est très
majestueux
j'aime beaucoup la crème l'accrochage
très aéré les explications sont très
claires les cartels bien fait donc pour
l'instant je suis très content parce
qu'on veut vraiment agréable à la fois
dans la forme historique qui était déjà
mais dans la façon de ce qu'il a été
refait on se rend compte qu'il ya des
espaces qui sont super beau et je suis
contente de revoir toutes les oeuvres
qui avait disparu du public des yeux du
public est avec nous ce soir franck
supplisson président de l'agglomération
montargoise bonsoir qu'est ce que ça
vous fait de voir ce lieu enfin ouvert
aux montargois beaucoup d'émotion ce
fait dix ans que ce projet a été lancé
six en travaux six ans de fermeture une
catastrophe avec les inondations qui ont
touché les collections un travail
considérable de restauration par les
plus grands experts de la restauration
du monde qui ont permis de faire revivre
ces oeuvres et de les mettre dans des
états dans lesquels on n'est jamais vu
depuis plus de 150 ans et donc beaucoup
d'émotion découvrir ses tableaux de
retour à montargis beaucoup d'émotion
une belle inauguration francs cristers
le ministre de la culture a même fait le
déplacement pour l'occasion
un comité d'accueil de gilet jaune était
aussi là pour son arrivée environ une
trentaine de gilet jaune ce qui ne l'a
pas empêché de prononcer son discours
aux côtés des élus de la région
vous propose d'écouter le ministre de la
culture en étant ici aujourd'hui on
montre que l'état est aussi très
impliquée dans dans la volonté de faire
vivre la culture partout et notamment
dans les territoires qui ont été marqués
particulièrement ici par les
dégradations liées aux inondations de
il ya une mobilisation exceptionnelle
d'abord des habitants de nos tares j des
élus locaux des associations les amis du
musée de girodet mais aussi l'état qui
s'est associée à ce mouvement pour
essayer de limiter au maximum les traces
qu'ils ont été observés avec ces
inondations
et avec cette restauration du musée on
voit que la mobilisation a payé
frank supplisson on parle d'un coût de
10 millions d'euros pour la rénovation
de ce musée qui a participé à ce
financement
vous avez raison c'est 10 millions
d'euros de coût et ont participé à ce
financement l'état la région le
département et l'agglomération
pourquoi était-il nécessaire de rénover
ce lieu est plus que nécessaire c'était
indispensable le musée géré au décès un
élément clé l'identité de montargis
l'identité du bassin de vie de montargis
à 200000 habitants dans ce bassin du
montargois et ce musée est un élément de
leur identité et pour les travaux il a
fallu respecter ce bâtiment qui date du
19e siècle
c'est un bâtiment qui date du milieu du
19e qu'un bâtiment historique à héberger
l'hôtel de ville qu'à héberger un centre
de formation qu'a eu de nombreuses
affectations dans sa vie qui fait partie
aussi le l'histoire du bassin montargois
qui a une histoire très importante et
les montargois ils sont très attachés
aux fesses un bâtiment qui a été
construit sur le legs d'un ancien
officier de la grande armée de napoléon
n'est mort à montargis et qui fait
partie de l'histoire de la ville et pour
l'anecdote la mairie à conserver ici
dans le musée une salle où est célébrée
où sont célébrés les mariages exactement
ça fait un siècle et demi que tous les
montargois viennent se marier au rez de
chaussée de ce bâtiment c'est dire
l'importance de ce lieu pour les
montargois aujourd'hui l'objectif du
bâtiment entièrement rénové j'imagine
pour vous c'est de rayonner dans le
département dans la région et même plus
loin encore beaucoup plus loin
les oeuvres de j rodez nous les prêtons
à new york à chicago à montréal à tokyo
sont les actions rechercher partout dans
le monde
j'ai rodez c'est un artiste phare du
début de 19e à l'égal d'un jéricho d'un
david un delacroix et donc on a la
chance extrême d'avoir à montargis
artiste à renommée mondiale à consonance
mondiale et à talant mondiale l artiste
méconnu non je pense que tous les
amateurs d'art le connaissent après on
mérite de le faire plus connaître auprès
du grand public mais j'ai rodez était le
portraitiste officiel de l'empereur
était à gagner le salon des arts
régulièrement et dominer jéricho dans
les salons artistiques de l'époque
et donc c'est un artiste qui a rien à
envier aux jéricho da vidéo de la croix
est aujourd'hui donc c'est l'idée c'est
de faire découvrir au grand public cette
oeuvre de jirau d ici 2 dé faire
découvrir ce lieu aussi un lieu de vie
exactement le musée géraud des coms
malraux ce n'est pas un musée c'est un
lieu de confrontation avec le public des
oeuvres des artistes qui vont aussi
venir se produire des expositions et je
vous invite en particulier en septembre
prochain l'exposition jéricho face à j
rodez ou giraudet face à jericho ou
giraudet en 1819 au classement des
peintures a vaincu jéricho qui exposait
le radeau de la méduse ans qu'on aura en
septembre 2019 le radeau de la méduse en
exposition au musée du rhône et sera à
suivre merci beaucoup frank supplisson
le musée girodet un musée qui a donc un
lieu qui a donc eu plusieurs vies
l'édifice a été construit au 19e siècle
on l'a dit il abritait à l'hôtel de
ville avant de devenir un lieu de
culture
les travaux donc on dirait six ans avec
une mésaventure des inondations de juin
2016 julien dernier et vincent logerot
nous explique tout cela les travaux de
réfection et d'agrandissement du musée
sont enfin terminés un chantier à 10
millions d'euros
la surface totale a été doublée grâce à
ces extensions réalisées à l'arrière on
était un petit peu juste
maintenant avec la création d'un nouvel
espace nous avons des salles
d'exposition supplémentaires des bureaux
une bibliothèque des ateliers des
réserves bien sûr l'édifice d'origine
datent du 19e siècle et la ville de
montargis le doigt philippe françois
d'urzy un militaire du pays
à sa mort en 1851 il a légué 660 mille
francs à la ville pour construire une
école professionnelle l'hôtel d'urzy
voit le jour en 1855 à cette école était
adjointe amusé alors à tous les étages
du bâtiment devait être utilisés vous
pour mettre sa bibliothèque qui avait
plus de 6000 ouvrages et amusé pour
mettre tous les tableaux posséder la
ville de montargis en 1881 l'école
laisse la place à l'hôtel de ville qui
restera durant un siècle dans l'actuel
musée
après six ans de fermeture les
montargois redécouvre giraudet le
chantier a pris du retard entre le
changement d'architectes et les dégâts
occasionnés par les inondations au
printemps 2016 des inondations qui ont
beaucoup marqué ici à montargis il ya
deux ans on s'en souvient grands soirs
sidonie le me ferez tôt vous êtes chargé
des collections ici au musée girodet
comment vous les avez vécu vous ces
inondations
mais écoutez comme comme tout le
personnel du musée de plein fouet
on va dire voilà mais on s'est très vite
remis au travail après et surtout on a
été extrêmement comment dire porter on
peut dire qu'on était portée par le
mouvement de bénévolat que les
conservateurs restaurateurs ont initié
de man par le biais de relations
amicales parce que le musée a payé un
lourd tribut ces inondations de juin
je crois que 80% des collections se sont
retrouvés sous l'eau malheureusement oui
90% des collections se sont retrouvés
sous l'eau et s'ils ont pu être sauvées
donc dans un premier temps c'est ce
mouvement de bénévolat des conservateurs
restaurateurs qui sont vraiment venu
sauver les oeuvres et en deuxième lieu
les subventions que le musée a pu
obtenir auprès de l'état de la région et
du département comment ça s'est passé ce
sauvetage des oeuvres et l'écouté de
manière assez improvisé parce
qu'évidemment c'est des choses qu'on ne
prévoit pas
mais à 6 organisé visons que
l'agglomération a missionné beaucoup de
personnes pour venir aider à retirer les
oeuvres de la réserve
et pendant ce temps là les conservateurs
restaurateurs se sont organisés pour
prendre soin des oeuvres au fur et à
mesure qu'elle sortait de la réserve
et puis après le musée a missionné des
personnes pour xp qu'une surveillance
durant l'été de conservation j'imagine
que pour vous après toutes ces aventures
mésaventure c'est un grand jour un beau
jour aujourd'hui exactement
voilà c'est un jour très émouvant de
retrouver sur les cimaises ses oeuvres
qu'on a vu vraiment atteinte par les
inondations est l'occasion de cette
réouverture le musée propose de
découvrir ou de redécouvrir l'oeuvre
d'anne louis giraud des ce génie de la
peinture un élève de david qui marqua
son époque avec son style poétique et
sensuel c'est ce que nous raconte à 13
ans pierre bouche l'eau et vincent
logerot and louis giraud des trios zoo
faisons simple appelons le giro b/g
rodez aura couvert l'ancien régime la
révolution l'empiré enfin la
restauration
cet élève de david mais en 1767 à
montargis aura connu une carrière dont
l'apogée académique se trouve exposé ici
c'est l'un des 36 portrait commandé par
napoléon avec cette petite difficulté
l'empereur ne posait pas giraudet est
allé à saint cloud au théâtre voir
napoléon et faire des études de visage
on reconnaîtra au 4 d'après lesquels il
a pu reproduire les traits de l'empereur
donc ça c'était une petite anecdote
amusante ensuite vous voyez la
composition est très soignée tout est
codifié le code civil sur la table les
abeilles sur le tapis vert
les accords de couleurs aussi le vert et
le rouge complémentaire donc c'est un
tableau en fait énormément construit
giraudier ne saurait être réduit à cet
exercice de commandes
son oeuvre annonce aussi le romantisme
avec ce portrait d'oriental c'est un
portrait d'oriental qu'on appelle
l'indien suivant les noms dans lequel on
trouve dans les archives et c'est un
portrait que giraudet à garder chez lui
donc c'est entre le portrait l'étude
il l'a fait pour se faire plaisir parce
qu'il aimait beaucoup lorient et il
était ouvert à toutes sortes de
pittoresque dans ceux des pays du soleil
levant
l'oeuvre préféré de sidonie protège sa
fragile peinture dépourvu de vernis sous
un abri de verre j'ai un faible pour le
tableau qui est derrière vous qui êtes
une petite odalisque parce qu'elle est
non terminés et donc c'est un tableau
une huile sur toi qui n'a pas été verni
qui est sorti de l'atelier de girodet et
on voit vraiment la main du maître son
travail ça me touche beaucoup
il va te trois peintures et les 130
dessins signés giraud des plus le fonds
d'oeuvres anciennes dans ce magnifique
saint-jérôme de francisco ou barran
montargis venant donner l'accès au plus
grand nombre possible
on doit forcément faire venir des gens
pour toutes sortes de raisons donc on va
avoir des entrepôts s'ils vont ou louer
des espaces pour venir faire des
colloques ou que sais-je d'entreprise
on va avoir des associations qu'on va
recevoir on va avoir des publics
constitués on va voir des gens qui sont
les autocaristes
on va voir le tourisme évidemment est
tous assez pour que ça soit un lieu de
vie qui a le maximum d'activités de
passage dans ce musée
après à nous de nous emparer pour
montrer ce qu'on a montré à l'automne
prochain le musée girodet s'apprête à
montrer plus encore en organisant une
exposition de niveau dit-on
internationaux
et sidonie le me ferez taux est toujours
avec nous vous êtes chargé des
collections ici au musée girodet qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire de cette
future nouvelle exposition qui a attendu
d'un niveau international en septembre
prochain
oui on a eu le plaisir d'apprendre par
le ministre qu'elle avait reçu le label
d'intérêt national donc pour nous c'est
une extrême reconnaissance alors c'est
la première grande exposition qui se
tiendra au musée girodet après leur
ouverture donc vraiment là le prochain
rendez vous auquel on vous convient elle
se portera sur le salon de 1819 ou a été
exposé pour la première fois le radeau
de la méduse de géricault qu'ils étaient
confrontés alors à une peinture de
girodet qui s'appelle pygmalion et
galatée et pygmalion et galatée était
alors le chef-d'oeuvre reconnu comme tel
et donc j rodez le peintre le maître
reconnu par tous et le radeau de la
méduse a reçu des critiques très
virulentes donc c'est amusant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui jéricho est plus connu
que giraudet et on va essayer de faire
une belle exposition autour de ce sujet
qui est vraiment là le sujet de la
naissance du romantisme
qu'est ce qui vous plaît vous dans
l'oeuvre de jirau d un tout évidemment
surtout sa diversité et son originalité
parce que j'étais capable de peindre un
portrait de napoléon en pied très très
impérial et puis comme on a derrière
nous un portrait d'oriental
extraordinaire avec un coloris
magnifique voilà ses qualités de
dessinateur et de coloriser une
influence une belle influence notamment
de tout l'esprit orientale merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
voilà vous savez tout du musée du musée
girodet il est ouvert jusqu'à 20 heures
ce soir ça va reprendre également
mercredi à 14h c'est gratuit profitez en
lui si ça vous tente
eh bien pourquoi pas merci beaucoup à
rebecca bengo rec